with nvidia and AMD releasing their new
GPUs you want to get a new graphics card
which one do you get the answer is going
to depend on your needs and budget and
I'm here to help most gamers use a 1080p
monitor with a 60 Hertz for fresh wave
this means any frames rendered above 60
frames per second will effectively go to
waste since most PC gamers don't have a
hybrid first rate monitor and don't have
a ton of cash lying around Nvidia's
GeForce GTX 1060 is a smart choice for
most people the card starts at two
hundred fifty dollars and is generally
as fast as Nvidia's former flagship GPE
the gtx 980 this card retailed for five
hundred fifty dollars just two years ago
the 1060 is a great card for maxing out
every pc game at 1080p with playable
frame rates it's also card that can
handle most games at 1440p and beyond if
you don't mind slightly less performance
to get more bang for the buck AMD's our
x 480 is also a great solution for 1080p
the RX 480 starts at two hundred dollars
for the four gigabyte model and scales
up to two hundred forty dollars for the
eight gigabyte now it's generally a
little faster than 2014 s4 GTX 970 which
is the baseline card you'll need for
viola it also costs roughly a third less
today while it's generally slower than
the GTX 980 it is faster than it for V
on if you're looking for the most
affordable car to get you to be on the
RX 480 if you're looking for something
even cheaper AMD has announced its RX
470 and 460 graphics cards but what if
you want to move to the opposite end of
the performance spectrum and buy a
really badass card nvidia recently
announced its twelve hundred dollar
titan x GPU yes there is already a tight
and x card out on the market but this is
a different one that will use the
company's new pascal architecture it's
confusing we know we also don't have the
card yet yielded the fastest card that
we have right now is Nvidia's GeForce
GTX 1080 it's pretty pricey starting at
six hundred dollars but it manages to
trade blows with 29 80s in sli it's also
definitively faster than Nvidia's older
one thousand dollar titan x GP it's the
best car for vr that we've tested so far
and we'll be able to max out most games
at 4k with playable frameworks just most
you say well yeah really texting games
like metro last light at 4k with
everything cranked up will likely need
two graphics cards to max out things
with silky smooth friendlies with 4k
being four times as sharp as 1080p can
really be taxing on a hardware you can
disable anti-aliasing to get some more
performance but contrary to bleak you
can still make out the juggies on a
2160p monitor without a bay but what if
you want high-end performance but don't
have the money to shell for to txt me
well then i'd recommend a gtx 1070 it's
about as fast as 2015's titan x for less
than half the cost it's a great card for
1440p or if you want to take advantage
of a high refresh rate 1080p monitor so
there you have it those are the latest
cheap used at the market for more
information on each card make sure to
read my in-depth written reviews